si nous continuons l'évolution actuelle
de la population et de la production
industrielle démentiel nous allons à
l'effondrement total de l'offre notre
planète de la vie sur la terre vers le
milieu du siècle prochain
dans le message de 1974
en écho avec l'actualité rené dumont
agronome de réputation mondiale a tout
fait pour nous alerter sur l'état de la
planète pendant des années il fonde un
groupe plus parler gentiment il faut
hurler puisque nous allons droit à la
mort après avoir soutenu de production
agricole massive pendant et après la
guerre il remet en cause ce modèle dans
les années 70 rené dumont craint une
feinte civilisationnel nous sommes de
mieux en mieux nourri de mes jambes me
gaver nous nous gaspillons et nous pas
lui enlever plusieurs couches qui risque
de conduire utilisation à la ruine
nous gaspillons tout l'énergie la
nourriture c'est le constat de rené
dumont en 1974
et voici les solutions qu'il propose
alors il faut d'abord limiter la
population ensuite limiter l'utilisation
par cette population de l'énergie est
ensuite envisager d'autres formes
d'énergie dont on est sûr qu'elles ne
sont pas dangereuses
l'énergie solaire l'énergie du vent
l'énergie géothermique en pensant aux
trois exemples mais on pourrait en citer
bien d'autres noms discours inaudible à
l'époque pour se faire entendre cette
même année 74 ans rené dumont se lance
en politique il est le tout premier
candidat à la présidentielle sous
l'étiquette écologique la voiture ça pue
ça pollue ça rend con
sa campagne des tonnes pour l'époque car
rené dumont c'est un sacré personnage
lui et son éternel pull rouge attire les
médias sans compter ses mises en scène à
la télé le bois devant vous un verre
d'eau précieuse puisque avant la fin du
siècle si nous continuons un tel
débordement elle manquera l'opinion
s'intéressent à ce personnage mais le
lui accordera 15,3 pour cent des voix
sur les plateaux ou dans ses
innombrables livres
rené dumont a attiré notre attention sur
le sort de notre planète jusqu'à sa mort
en 2001 ces craintes d'hier inaudible à
l'époque sont aujourd'hui confirmées par
les rapports alarmants sur
l'environnement
[Musique]